i'm a firm believer that if you're not
making noise with your work and you
gotta call agents and people to
represent you then your work is not
what's your advice to people on getting
representation whether it's for film
screenwriting acting
well i think that
um having representation and how it
comes to you and the the need for it is
they're separate you have to keep them
separate i think if you're an actor you
need it
um it's an agent's job is to go through
the breakdowns and submit you for roles
to get you taped auditions are in the
room i mean an actor can't act without
people knowing they exist
i think that uh cinematographers that's
very important too i think agents can be
very beneficial to a cinematographer's
career
um
by and large agents sit around wait for
the phone to ring i mean let's call it
like it is the days of agents reading
scripts
taking 20 or 30 home a weekend and
discovering new property and calling an
actor and saying i just read something
you've got to read let's call the
producers and tell them you want to do
this
you know a lot of agents wait for the
phone to ring
and i think that
when writers directors and filmmakers
ask about getting representation i'm a
firm believer that you're either chasing
it or it's chasing you
and i talk about this a lot in the book
a big chunk of it about representation
and being a filmmaker
and
you know i'm a firm believer that if if
you're not making noise with your work
and you got to call agents and people to
represent you then your work is not
going to be something that they're going
to have a real easy time getting behind
and selling
and i know that's very harsh to say look
i've been through 100 agents and
managers
and i've never gotten a job from one not
one
and i've been with some big agencies and
big managers and maybe it's my fault
maybe i'm just horrible and unsellable
but um
i get asked a lot from from young
writers who may have had a short film
made or
producers who are trying to you know
sell sell what they're doing to a bigger
scale
and
you know things today especially with
the changes in our industry in the last
few years
um agencies that are respectable and
real they they're kind of signing people
by committee now it's not
hip pocketing
you know the days of an agent taking
somebody kind of off the grid in their
back pocket and trying to do something
with that is is really frowned upon
and is something that's really not done
as much anymore if at all
so
when you go in with a with a resume and
a body of work that you might have
uh and try to get representation you you
have to you know they're gonna check
with everybody from the janitor to the
parking attendant to make sure if they
should sign you or not it's it's not
just somebody falling in love with you
and unless it's somebody who runs a
boutique on their own that they are the
judge jury and executioner but
i have found that when when you seek out
representation and you have to kind of
do a tap dance to get them to want to
get behind your work and your abilities
um i always say you know let's see where
that that relationship is in six months
um they usually don't bear much fruit
and and that's
you know uh it's unfortunate it's hard
to get representation as a writer as a
producer as a director in this town
that said it is not hard to create
original content that if it's good
enough can get the attention
of a respectable agent or a manager
you know again we we have endless
resources for so cheap
as filmmakers even even student
filmmakers you know you can get a dslr
you can get actors and again don't hire
your cousin and your mother to be in
them go to acting schools and call the
people that run these acting schools and
say i'm making a short i'm doing a spec
commercial give me some good talent
there are people out there that actually
know how to act that you can get
and
put stuff together if you know if you're
hurdle is well i can't get anything done
because i can't get any money or i can't
get anything done because nobody's
behind me then you have to create the
content and if you don't have the
content created how are people going to
know if you're worthy of being
represented or not i'm not trying to
discourage anybody from trying to get
representation and i'm sure there are
those wonderful relationships where the
artist has banged down the door enough
times and the agent finally said okay
i'll rep you and it's gone well there
are those exceptions but by and large
the majority of the time you know
first-time writers and i say first-time
writers and i finished a screenplay or i
have a book on amazon
where's my agent it doesn't work that
way
and if it does
you know let's see how that went after
six months i just don't think
that when you have to
try to convince somebody to represent
you
um that that that's that's a passion i
think when a true agent or manager gets
behind somebody i think they have to be
passionate about them
i think they have to be they're they're
working for the artist and they have
they only get paid on commission and who
are they going to spend their days
banging down the doors for you know and
if if you're an actor i really believe
you need an agent um but talking about
the filmmaker side it's tough to get
representation and and i
i often tell filmmakers don't don't spin
your wheels and
burn your calories trying to get an
agent just the amount of time you're
trying to burn the phones to find an
agent you should be shooting something
that's going to make an agent say holy
i saw this on youtube i saw this on
you know vimeo i saw this at a film
festival
or at least if you are going to bang on
those doors you should have three or
four
short films or something
you know i know a very successful
commercial director who's who's been at
the top of the game for many years
and i asked him once i said how did you
get in the game you know you didn't come
from film school you didn't have parents
that could you know he said hey man i
got a camera i got i i got friends who
could act i got guys who can hold sound
and i knew how to direct i knew how to
cut
and i went out and i started doing spec
commercials like he did doritos
coca-cola pepsi he would just grab
product and do these incredible you know
how like doritos would have these
contests where you know create your own
create your own campaign and maybe we'll
use it you know he would just do that
for everything he would do cars like if
his mom got a new bmw mom let me let me
make a car commercial for bmw and this
guy had like 20 or 30 commercials
and they all looked like really big
commercials and he was able to go in and
say this is what i can do this is who
you're representing keep in mind when
you go to an agent they need content to
sell you because they're going to make
phone calls or emails
on your behalf and the decision makers
are going to say great let me see their
work and if you don't have work
the agent's job you're kind of
you're kind of kneecapping the agent
going in because they're going to come
to you and say you got to get me content
and it's it can't be looked at as a
chicken or egg type thing that's an
excuse the filmmaker the artist has to
get out there
and and create the content now if you're
a writer i'm a firm believer that you
may you may excel or be passionate about
writing one thing i think it's important
if you're unknown to really stretch and
try to try to get three or four spec
scripts done in different genres because
there are companies that are just making
thrillers that may read your script that
an agent can take to somebody like mar
vista and and say hey you're doing a
bunch of stuff for a lifetime look at
this
if the agent can get it in the room
it'll get a look
but there's also companies that only do
horror there's companies like hallmark
that only do romantic comedies or
whatever those things are called and if
if you're a writer that's looking to get
representation the agent is going to
want and need as much ammunition as
possible you have to make their job easy
and if you give them three or four
different
you know a pallet of different things
they're going to be able to circulate
three or four different scripts maybe 15
or 20 different companies think about
what the odds just come of you not only
getting somebody in your corner to
represent you but getting seen and
getting a reputation
a wonderful
woman i met
a year and a half ago at a webinar
right when kovitz started
brilliant writer she writes these
beautiful romantic little you know films
that are just hallmark
and
and and she got she got a script read
and she got a green light and she got
the film produced and now she's a
working writer
and
she
we talked about it and she was like oh
my god i got genres in everything this
woman was pushing a genre but when it
came time to getting looked at and
getting representation she had a whole
plethora of stuff to give to them and
say look i can write anything
and that's what she's doing now and and
you have to you know i think too many of
us
sit around and wait for the phone to
ring or the door to get knocked on or
somebody to know somebody you have to be
so proactive
on on creating content to get people
excited about what you do i go back to
we talk about films like napoleon
dynamite started as a short saw was a
short
sling blade was a short you know
there's there's so many of those films
even whiplash was a short they obviously
did something right to get the attention
to get these things made into major
motion pictures that hasn't changed
you know people forget that those four
great films started from humble humble
beginnings i mean napoleon dynamite the
short was in black and white for crying
out loud i mean it's horrible but it was
great but it was it was so bad it was
good right
but that's how we have to think as
filmmakers you know james wan did it
brilliantly with his short for saw i
mean i encourage everybody go on youtube
find these films they're all there
they're all there you can find these
shorts and you will see
where billy bob thornton got sling blade
from you will see where you know
napoleon dynamite and whiplash all came
from because they're all they're all
there and they all started because
somebody said screw it i'm gonna do it.
and that's that's what i
tell people they need to do
so maybe we are too much in this mindset
of like i need to have my people do it
oh wait i don't have people i need to
get people i need to get people i i'm
i'm not successful until i have people
and we're not
willing to say wait a minute i'm not
there yet
a lot of people have a hard time saying
i'm not there yet and um that that's a
really good point karen um we all have
to be able to say we're not there yet
and truly identify and accept when we're
not and get over that next hump i mean i
i deal with a lot of actors that you
know
um when we do workshops and do acting
class you know work and it's awesome you
know like i need a team you need a team
for what you've had an agent for two
years you go out on 15 auditions a week
you're not booking you need to better
the craft you ever think maybe you're
just not good in a room do you ever
think maybe you need to study better you
know and look at the reel and half the
time they're not off book and they've
had the work for three days and you're
reading one scene you're not off book
yet these are the kind of things that
that really
will impact
an actor from getting
past
an audition and it's it's very hard
for artists you know we are so myopic we
are so self-centered anyway it's in our
nature
we we're very selfish people but when it
comes to getting to the next level it's
very very rare that somebody can look
and say it's me
i need to get off my butt and create
content i need to get into acting class
two or three nights a week i need to go
take a class in basic lighting if i
really want to be a cinematographer or a
director i need to understand lenses i
need to you know i tell everybody who
wants to write produce direct
and and get in the edit bay that's where
you're going to learn it more than
anything because you're going to see
you're going to fix other people's
mistakes you're going to you're going to
learn what ends up on a cutting room
floor you're going to realize the amount
of time you waste on a set and what
that'll do is it'll better you when you
make your short films and it'll better
you when when writing scripts i mean
it's amazing how many writers have never
been in the edit bay that's the most
important place you know there are three
scripts there's the one you write the
one that's shot and the one that's cut
and if you can if you can bridge the gap
between the one that's written and the
one that's released boy
you know it's a it's a helpful tool and
i know writers are going to bash me for
saying that but you know get your button
to write any edit bay and realize what
what you write and how it affects
you know
production costs and you know
putting certain amount of characters in
a certain scene and you got to remember
you got to cover all that get multiple
takes on every actor you know
and and what that does production is a
lot of good you know we talk about this
in other another webinars i've done and
you know the writer needs to understand
a production mindset
because there are some great scripts out
there that that don't get read past 20
or 30 pages and it's because they don't
understand it from a produceral view
where you really have to think about
when you write a script you can say well
it shouldn't be that expensive it just
takes place in a flat in new york
you know and well okay how many people
are in it you know how many different
locations what is your logistics here
and you have to think of who you're
going after you realistically to produce
it and does it fit
in what they're doing
it's about finding that connection with
a producer with your written word but
also kind of going back to what you said
making an agent's job easier if you have
an agent that isn't wme or caa level
that's not going to kick down doors and
get you to every studio
you got to realize the level of the
agent or manager you're working with and
where they have the ability to get you
now if you are able to
work with somebody and somebody is
showing interest in working with you i
think it's very important you have that
talk early on is what is your ability to
get me through the door what are the
studios networks production shingles
whatever they call them
where can you get my stuff read so that
artist that writer can understand okay
this manager can only get me in a
hallmark so they need to start thinking
about okay let me get this stuff
together for you that's going to give
you the path of least resistance start
getting my my stuff to you that you can
go to hallmark with or is it lifetime
let me get you some thrillers let me get
you some you know husband came out of
jail wants to see his kid scripts let me
give you some of those and you know and
that's that's important it's not just
about being a good writer it's about
finding a match
and finding out who your potential
representatives have the ability or
juice to get to
so the work that you submit to them
it resonates with the people that it's
ultimately going to get read by because
if you have a great script and the
people that are reading it have no
business making a film like that or no
interest in making a story like that it
doesn't matter it's just wasted time
what if someone says though that i'm not
a diy person like that i i i want my you
know i i'm kind of grew up with staff
and different things so i need i need to
have my people do this well if you've
grown up with staff you should be able
to write checks so write check and go
make a movie i mean that's fine i mean
i'm sorry but yeah i i think you're in
the wrong business i mean it's it's very
rare that somebody can sit in a basement
and just crank out scripts and the day
is gonna come or that script is read by
you know the right agent or the right
assistant to an actor and i mean there's
always the lottery i mean people win the
lottery that's true
you know i think the odds are about the
same but i i think you need to if you're
not diy and you need people and you need
a staff then what i think you need to do
is find other people that are
needing a staff but one of them has a
camera and one of them is an actor and
one of them may be an editor and work
together we talked earlier about people
working together and building something
special and building building a team
everybody having a common goal you know
to get to the next level and that's what
i tell a lot of writers i said you know
the cool thing about being a writer is
you don't need anybody to tell you to go
to work you you really have the only job
in this industry that you you may not
get paid yet
or at all but
nobody can tell you you can't work right
now you have the ability to roll out of
bed turn on a light at two in the
morning and write and that's a beautiful
thing because an actor is not going to
be able to get in front of a camera and
tap dance unless there's a script
director doesn't have anything to direct
unless there's a script there's nothing
to produce without a script the writers
are essential i mean it's so important
it's an incredible position to be in
if you're not able to be a writer
producer director editor or filmmaker
and all your focus is on writing then
you need to get out more and you need to
find people of like mind that have those
skill sets or the materials to get your
products seen
it's just it's not going to sitting in a
pdf on an external hard drive or
you know somewhere on your computer is
not going to get it made it's about
getting it with people and i'm very big
you know a lot of people like to talk
about pitch decks and proof of concept
some of the most impressive things i've
seen are
when people go out and shoot a scene or
two or three
to me that's a real pitch deck that's a
proof of concept i don't want to see
papers and comps and actors you're never
going to acquire on your
proof of you know your your pitch deck i
i want to see you go out and shoot a
scene
for your film with comparable qualified
people
and
people that are passionate about it and
i think some of those true pocs that
i've seen they knock me out of my seat i
can't believe what people are putting
together these days
and i mean for nothing no money
there's no excuse
you